bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
universités grandes écoles école du
numérique
chaque établissement a avancé sa rentrée
une rentrée marquée par l'évolution des
formations et des apprentissages pour
répondre aux enjeux et métiers de demain
alors quelles sont les nouveautés pour
les étudiants les professionnels en
matière de formation et perspectives sur
le territoire saint quentinois
on vous explique tout c'est parti
[Musique]
créée en 1991 l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines est
aujourd'hui un pot d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche mondialement
reconnu répartis sur cinq campus dans
les yvelines
elle offre plus de 200 formations
diplômantes accueille dix neuf mille
étudiants concentre plus de 900
enseignants chercheurs et 39 structures
de recherche lu vs qu est classée parmi
les meilleures universités de la planète
dans le classement de shanghai et
notamment deuxième mondial dans le
domaine des sciences de l'atmosphère
merci de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines et universités
pluridisciplinaires
donc vous avez un très large éventail de
formations à tous niveaux
donc pour tous types de deux personnes
donc ça soit des prix des étudiants
primo-entrants les bacheliers comme on a
cette année où des personnes en
recherche d'emploi ou des personnes qui
sont actuellement employés d'entreprises
qui cherchent à monter en compétences
justement à travers les mécanismes de
formation continue
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est d'une part sa jeunesse
mais en plus de cette jeunesse elle a
quand même une notoriété à la fois
national et international pour certaines
certaines activités notamment tout ce
qui concerne les sciences les sciences
de la terre elle représente aujourd'hui
différentes différentes activités aussi
bien le droit les sciences les sciences
de la santé avec une faculté de médecine
régulièrement présente dans le
dans le top five des universités
françaises
autre domaine celui de la recherche et
notamment via la relation avec les
entreprises
nous avons une chaire ici par exemple
avec des entreprises telles que le
talent est tel que total et j'en oublie
donc des gros groupes
et puis lu vs qu à travers un de ses
laboratoires en particulier que le
laboratoire des sciences et flémalle
d'environnement mais aujourd'hui
qu'attendent réellement les acteurs du
territoire en matière d'enseignement et
de formation surtout une évolution pour
que notre université intègre bien sûr
paris saclay qu'est le grand projet est
également qu'elle soit le plus proche
possible du monde de l'entreprise du
monde de la recherche appliquée et
fondamental aussi mais qu'il y ait bien
sûr ce cette proximité avec les
laboratoires scientifiques et les
entreprises qui profitent vraiment à
notre identité dans le cadre de
l'intégration de paris de paris saclay
que nous nous proposons d'ailleurs
d'étendre certaines activités de 2,7 de
cette université avec notamment en étant
à même d'amener du foncier pour pouvoir
étendre cette université nous avons
également l'objectif d'accroître
certaines certains bâtiments de
l'université pour l'institut supérieur
de management qui est un des pôles
d'excellence de notre de notre
université et en même temps de mettre
une impulsion plus forte sur le
numérique puisque on voit bien que
la révolution s'accélère et que nos
entreprises ne trouvent pas les
potentiels dont elles ont besoin
alors le métier numérique ça toujours
été toute façon une priorité de notre
université est donc effectivement c'est
à la fois former les étudiants aux
métiers du numérique mais c'est
également les orienter vers vers toutes
les métiers les formations pour lequel
le numérique peut aider donc c'est
vraiment pour et par le numérique on a
une collaboration et un attachement
commun entre l'université et puis en
particulier la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à saint
quentin en yvelines dont on ait une
accélération sur le numérique parce que
il ya dix mille emplois sur saint
quentin qui ont pas été assez rapidement
satisfaits pour cela on a lancé cette
école
[Musique]
devenir développeur programmeur ou
encore expert en cybersécurité le
secteur recrute mais les entreprises
saint-quentinoise fait à trouver des
candidats suffisamment fort mais qui
puisse répondre à leurs besoins
aujourd'hui des formations labellisée
école numérique existe déjà sur le
territoire mais bientôt
l'offre devrait être élargi d'ici fin
novembre les locaux refaits à neuf du
prisme devrait accueillir de nouvelles
formations labellisée école numérique
simplon pote school ou o'clock devrait
proposer leur formation avant fin 2010 8
sur le territoire le cnam basé à
versailles sera l'un des acteurs de ces
nouvelles formations trois formations
très tôt dans le domaine informatique
dont des certificats de compétences et
des certificats professionnels
certificat de compétences donc avec une
entrée avec un niveau bac + 2 dans le
domaine de la sécurité de l'information
et tout ce qui est réseau informatique
et en certificats professionnels
accessibles d'élus niveau bac dans la
programmation de si près de 3 formation
labellisée école du numérique par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on se rend compte que ceux des
formations et des métiers en tension où
il ya des grands besoins de recrutement
donc le clame s'est associé à la
communauté pour pouvoir proposer ces
formations à nos demandeurs d'emploi et
salariés sur le bassin en prend
[Musique]
et le code il est là donc tu le note
elle peut par ce code on tue fait un
copier-coller gueule tu veux bosser et
là tu fermes
un texte qui représente les instructions
de programmes écrite par un programmeur
un code qui n'aura bientôt plus de
secret pour ces stagiaires
créé en 1969 le centre de formation il
faut coop à montigny le bretonneux
dispense des cours en alternance pour
les adultes en reconversion
professionnelle
quatre mois en centre de formation
quatre mois en entreprise
une équation qui permet d'être
rapidement opérationnel
labellisée école numérique l'ifocop
propose aujourd'hui différentes
formations
c'est très varié ça va 2
du html css javascript mais ça va il ya
des cours un peu plus théorique comme
cahier des charges l'environnement
juridique tout ce qu'on peut faire tout
ce qu'on ne peut pas faire liés au web
c'est une station aussi en droit
d'auteur et le rer gpd donc initiation
au droit très importante également un
world press des cms pour apprendre à
faire d'un site rapidement et tout type
de site et développeur intégrateur web
on en a besoin il ya un manque 150
milles sur le marchand un besoin de 150
nul développeur intégrateur web et tout
ce qui touche à la programmation il avec
l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle ce sera un des métiers qui
vont être amenées encore plus à se
développer
une fois le site réalisé est nécessaire
de les faire vivre
c'est là qu'entre en piste les community
managers animer les réseaux sociaux m le
site à jour surveiller l'audience et le
référencement des compétences de plus en
plus recherchées dans un monde qui
twitte qui tchatche et qui résonnent les
personnes qui sont qui viennent ici les
personnes stagiaires qui suit une
formation on vienne d'horizons très
différents et ils sont généralement en
reconversion il souhaite aller vers des
métiers qui ont de l'avenir
et pas besoin d'avoir fait math sup ce
un candidat capable de faire un sudoku
en moins de quatre heures même à niveau
facile en moins de quatre heures les
capable de devenir développeur
intégrateur web ou community manager
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas besoin d'être
matin c'est juste logique acquérir la
formation permet l'obtention d'un
diplôme reconnu de niveau bac + 2 voire
bac + 3
[Musique]
à l'estaca il est aussi question des
métiers de demain
ici les questions de l'automobile de
l'aéronautique de domaine du spatial et
du ferroviaire avec quelques changements
pour la rentrée l'estaca école de
l'innovation par excellence ne pouvait
que se renouveler pour sa rentrée on a
fait évoluer un petit peu l'encadrement
de nos promotions d'abord en réduisant
le nombre d'élèves par ce que l'on
appelle les corps c'est-à-dire le groupe
d'élèves
on a constitué cette année des groupes
d'une cinquantaine d'élèves
par corps donc y aura six cordes en
première année pour cette rentrée
ça va permettre un meilleur suivi des
étudiants un meilleur suivi grâce
notamment à l'arrivée de nouveaux
enseignants et responsables de filières
venus renforcer les équipes
l'estaca poursuit également son
développement à l'international par le
biais de nouveaux partenariats
c'est des universités au canada aux
états unis en espagne mais aussi à une
allure citer encore et au pérou donc ça
ça offre davantage de possibilités à nos
étudiants qui ont l'obligation de partir
à l'international pendant leur cursus
afin d'inciter les jeunes ingénieurs à
plus d'autonomie l'école développe une
plateforme d'apprentissage numérique
plus de support en ligne afin que les
élèves puissent préparer leurs cours en
amont vidéo test d'autoévaluation ceci
afin de rendre l'élève acteur de sa
formation et dernière nouveauté en date
une formation continue avec à la clé un
diplôme pour le secteur des véhicules et
systèmes autonomes et connectée sein du
fomc est accessible à des salariés
d'entreprises donc qui ont moins 3
années d'expérience professionnelle et
un niveau de départ équivalent à un bac
+ 2 techniques technologiques dont la
possibilité de reprendre leurs études
rentrée sur un cycle d'ingénieur de 1200
heures en alternance durant ce cursus
ses salariés ont la possibilité de mener
trois projets à résoudre un parent le
diplôme a été créée à l'initiative des
entreprises
du secteur automobile et
c'est une demande forte qui s'est
exprimée des nouveaux enjeux sur le
véhicule autonome
et donc il y as besoin de faire monter
en compétences des salariés dans ces
domaines là pour répondre aux besoins
des entreprises cinq domaines ont été
identifiés l'internet des objets le big
data
l'intelligence artificielle la cyber
sécurité et l'optimisation des aides à
la conduite à l'estaca le partenariat
avec les entreprises ne s'arrête pas là
grâce au réseau px les étudiants peuvent
se lancer dans l'aventuré de
l'entrepreneuriat
depuis deux ans une formation en option
sensibilise à la création d'entreprise
au sein du réseau des entreprises des
banquiers des coachs d'anciens élèves et
des incubateurs du territoire de paris
saclay le réseau pépites de paris saclay
donc des ips ça offre à la fois de la
sécurité et de la visibilité un étudiant
qui souhaitent entreprendre à la fois en
lui délivrant le statut de d'étudiants
entrepreneur et un diplôme d'études
durant entrepreneurs le des oeufs qui
permet à l'étudiant de poursuivre son
projet de création d'entreprise tout en
bénéficiant de la sécurité et
d'encadrement offertes dans le cadre de
ses études
[Musique]
premier campus audiovisuel d'europe
l'institut international de l'image et
du son 3e fête cette année ses 30 ans
une pérennité qui s'explique par la
pluralité des filières enseignées et la
réussite de ses étudiants et là encore
quelques surprises de rentrer les
chaleurs estivales se font encore sentir
mais sur le campus de troisième à
elancourt les apprentis cinéastes sont
déjà à l'oeuvre créée voilà trente ans
les colts audiovisuel accueille chaque
année 1700 étudiants est parti sur les
sites d'elancourt et de bordeaux 30 en
effet d'implantation sur territoire donc
c'est là que c'est un événement
important pour l'école puisque l'école
s'est développée en l'espace de trente
ans a ouvert de nouvelles filières les
parcours de bac à bac + 5 sont répartis
en cette filière cinéma et audiovisuel
son jeu vidéo animation 2d 3d techniques
du spectacle et cette année un nouveau
cursus en design graphique motion design
ainsi qu'une orientation designed espace
scénographique et des formations qui ont
évolué dans le temps et qui sont passés
sur des des reconnaissances au niveau 2
donc en l'occurrence et puis nous avons
eu lieu dernièrement
très belle reconnaissance puisque nous
avons obtenu un diplôme visé pour la
filière cinéma audiovisuel et son ce qui
est vrai un vrai bilan positif pour
l'établissement et se et ce dépôt mise
et nous l'avons obtenue dans le cadre de
notre entend donc tous coordonnant
relativement relativement bien dans nos
formations déjà des métiers évoluent nos
formations sont collectées au métier
donc de toutes façons par excellence on
doit on doit se renouveler pour faire
évoluer nos jeunes que l'on forme de
façon permanente
350 production par an 1800 entreprises
partenaires et 86 % d'insertion pour les
stagiaires de l'école dès la première
année d'obtention du diplôme
forte de ces résultats trois yes man
sera une nouvelle formation dès la
rentrée prochaine
celle des effets spéciaux la filière
cinéma devrait voir l'ouverture d'un
master en écriture et réalisations
ce climat que c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures saint-quentinoise
ciao
[Musique]